c'est pas juste aurait dû être nous qui
fait péter le champagne on devra porter
des diamants collectionner des pictons
albinos et moi je suis là comme un coing
balader avec un balai à chiotte dans les
mains
regardez les mecs même son chien lille
puma à cent mille abonnés passé au
crible tous les éclairages les liaisons
sont coupés patron
la fête est finie total e p on ferait
mieux de se rendre vous croyez pas
sortie poche je montre que je suis
parleurs et tes conneries on peut les
piéger j'ai une idée
c'est parti
mon plan à marcher et n'en a pas marché
je me suis pris une arme et dans le
thorax
j'vais me rhabille je reviens
[Musique]
sans à la hauteur
entre leurs armées on libère les otages
on est venus pour faire payer une taxe
aubert oued il aurait pas le moindre
dollar de ma poche cette femme vient de
chier dans sont en panne on se jure
c'est pas vrai je ne suis pas chez
dessus le traité de menteur quelqu'un a
effectivement pied dans son pantalon et
je ne dénoncerai personnes celles qui
vous envoient
[Applaudissements]
toujours
était prêt à devenir tom brake
la petite maison dans la prairie tu
penses qu'il a joué dans la petite
maison dans la prairie
il a un chapeau non non tu confonds
[Musique]
j'espère que vous ne m'avez pas recruter
pour ma ressemblance avec le hacker dans
piège de cristal
parce que je suis pas comme lui
[Musique]